[Music]
happy thanksgiving
happy thanksgiving
can i take joy to our house wear hat
please you're just getting over a cold
we're your sisters i can't find them
hannah joy i checked the entire house
they're not here
dad there's this rv and they were
playing on it there was then we thought
there was someone inside you wait here
let me know i couldn't find them
9-1-1 detective loki the children
detectives
i'm going to find your daughters
what do you got we didn't find anything
this thing's clean that boy has never
been in trouble a day in his life
they're letting him go what the police
said they're letting him go today
why aren't you saying someone had to go
arrest this guy well he has the iq of a
10 year old there's no way he could
abduct two girls and then make them
disappear maybe he wasn't on his own
we're considering all possibilities i
don't think you are considering all
possibilities just let me do my job
keep knocking on doors mind if i take a
look around
why do you tell me his name he said he
took them did he say he was with anybody
we found something
someone has to make him talk
or they're gonna die five days have been
gone now we run out of time
you don't even know that it's him i left
him on someone and he knows where this
guy is
this guy's a fake you're doing
the girls are still out there
hey lisa her name's not lisa i know but
if every time i say hey lisa
she'll think that i dated a girl who
looked just like her she'll develop this
unconscious need to win my approval and
from then on it's cake
damn why would you want to be a
pharmaceutical rep that pays over 100
grand a year that's why
hello ladies hello gorgeous oh wait yep
there's another one if a patient asks
you're an intern hi
i'm dr knight and who are you jamie
randle
intern well let's have a look
you're a drunk rap you
okay i apologize let me take you out for
a cup of coffee strong eye contact
implied intimacy
you're good so you always this mean
actually this is me being nice you have
beautiful eyes
that's it that's the best you got this
isn't about connection for you
this isn't even about sex for you this
is about finding an hour or two of
relief from the pain of being you
and that's fine with me because only
one's the exact same
why don't you have a boyfriend let's
just keep it simple i can do that
[Music]
hello i like hearing the sound of your
voice you like hearing the sound of her
voice were you abducted by aliens
i hear we're coming out with a new sex
drug viagra i want it
this is a revolution i've already sold
2000 prescriptions this month alone it's
hard to believe
isn't it it's hard to believe
you're a good man but you're on the fast
track 600 girls
dying to discuss sales techniques can't
do that with me and holding you back
she rejected you that's why you want her
i need you
i'm gonna need you more
[Music]
i'm sorry i know it's so late
oh my god oh my god
thank you spider-man that was so good
hey sorry i'm late happy you look nice
thank you you too
thank you new dress yes it is how'd you
know
what just happened
[Music]
planning a trip mm-hmm going to europe
school trip
did you get your passport peter parker
here to pick up a passport please
mini toothpaste pack your suit
i just want to go on my trip with my
friends europe doesn't really need a
friendly neighborhood spider-man
you look really pretty and therefore i
have value no no
that's not i'm messing with you you look
pretty too
i just want to spend some time with mj i
think she really likes you dude it
reminds me when i first saw those i had
just finished my phone call
so nice to finally meet you spiderman
you're nick fury put some clothes on
let's go for a ride
is he gonna be okay like that might want
to turn him over so he doesn't swallow
his tongue
i think nick fury just hijacked our
summer vacation
awesome
got gifts parker but you have a job to
do
are you going to step up or not
you're alone your friends are in trouble
what are you gonna do about it
you don't want any part of this
who is that guy he's like iron man and
thor rolled into one
he's no spider-man what is it with you
and spider-man what he looks out for the
neighborhood has a dope suit and i
really respect him
sup dickwad
listen up this young lady here is
running the marathon
for bringing a women's hospital so skip
around a stalwart and donate to a good
cause
[Applause]
i'm going to be there at the finish line
for you i'm gonna make a big sign for
you
doesn't show up for anything
and then he shows up
there was an explosion and your legs
they're gone
[Music]
welcome home is it good to be back what
are you doing
uh talking to you what are you doing
dancing
[Music]
you're trying to make a hero out of me
you need to tell your family what's
going on with you
take my mom
[Music]
this is the first time you're in this
week and you have three appointments i
can't i can't i can't do it i gave up my
family
i'm not giving this up i can't do it why
do you even want me
you remind me of my son he died
helping you made me feel like i could
help my son
and for that i am grateful you're
grateful
[Music]
[Applause]
you showed the world that they can't
break us no matter what the hell they do
there was this time in the hospital when
like i just want to give up
look at this boston straw
and now i just want to live
i just want people to see how amazing my
son is
i'm gonna walk you know i'm gonna walk
with you again someday
[Music]
hey guys it's a girl congratulations do
you have any idea who the father is
shut up for story time
all right let's go three two one
[Music]
this is dr david jordan our mission is
to intercept a research pod from mars
16 steps to fix a shower i'm an
astronaut not a gym teacher
this is the first capsule ever to come
back from the planet we have visual
confirmation
i see it this could be a major
scientific breakthrough
we're looking at the first proof of life
beyond earth
lowering oxygen more carbon dioxide
that's beautiful you're finally a daddy
it's gonna be a big custody battle over
this one
are you gonna bring the martian back to
earth no we're gonna keep it up here
we're gonna study where it's safe
look how fast it's growing every single
cell is a muscle cell
and a nerve cell or muscle or brain
how smart is this thing
these creatures wiped out mars millions
of years ago
if we let it get to earth we'll risk all
human life
let's kill the thing
good night moon good night roon
good night cow jumping over the moon
good night light and the red balloon
what is the prime instinct of any life
form
to survive grenade stars
we've lost all communication good night
air we'll hit the atmosphere in 39
minutes we won't survive
but it could good night noises
everywhere
[Music]
this is no ordinary dagger
releasing the sand turns back time only
the holder of the dagger is aware of
what's happened
did you see that
[Music]
prince dustin have you wondered how you
could have found
such a treasure are you not curious why
an orphan from the streets
[Music]
would be chosen to become a prince the
gods have a plan for you
a destiny there are those who would use
the power of the dagger
to destroy the world time will erase
everything
you must protect it
who were these demons as sansans trained
in the art of quick death
the secret guardian temple
is the one place the dagger can be
safely hidden
take it there dastan
you really enjoy telling me what to do
don't you only because you're so good at
following orders yeah
don't press your luck the dagger
must be found
[Music]
such a noble prince leaping to assist
the fallen beauty
who said you're a beauty there must be a
reason why you can't take your eyes off
me
your i it's time
give me the dodger
how did you do that
that's impossible difficult
not impossible
dear champion vending company
i put five quarters in your machine and
proceeded to push b2
which should have given me peanut m ms
regrettably it did not
i found this upsetting as i was very
hungry and also my wife had died 10
minutes earlier
i'm not saying that was your fault i
just want to be thorough
julia was a good person she worked with
special needs children
she snorted when she laughed other than
that i don't think i knew who she really
was
now that she's gone i don't even feel
sad or pain
where exactly are you feeling no sort of
in this whole
area right here
preparing the human heart is like
repairing an automobile
you have to take everything apart just
examine
everything then you can put it all back
together
that made me think vending co what if
that's not possible
i'm calling in regards to your complaint
letters there's been four so far
do you have anyone to talk to do you
usually make service calls at two in the
morning
[Music]
you miss her i'm trying to i still have
time
are you for real right now there's some
random guy eating in our house
the man's wife just died have some
compassion shouldn't you be in school
i'm suspended or what
[Music]
did you take apart the washroom stall
that was my work yes
why that's a little harder to answer
what are we doing again
we're taking apart my marriage
do you think it's too late to put it all
back together
[Music]
wake up tony
i made a new friend real or imaginary
do you believe in time travel
[Music]
i'm gonna tell you a little story today
[Music]
about a young man
[Music]
whose life was completely destroyed by
fear
[Music]
tell mom and dad why stop taking your
[Music]
medications
[Music]
you give yourself to me
wake up connie
[Music]
you